Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Bonjour, mes amis. Welcome to The Rest. It is history. I, Hercule Poirot, have invited you here into the library to answer for you a mystery
very profound. The fire, it is roaring in the grate. The butler, he is serving the sherry. Very profound. And what is it I wish to reveal? Why, a mystery very strange. How is it that one English writer has sold more than two billion copies of her novels? What does it say about her laughing times? What does it say about us that we still read and watch adaptations of her novels, even now almost fifty years after her death? I talk, of course, of Madame Agatha Christie, and to explain her, it requires the application of the little grasselles, the process of the
thought logique. But, of course, I would not be Hercule Poirot if i did not have a sidekick a bone-headed anglo-saxon dominic sandbrook that was of course agatha christie's great fictional creation david suchet so tom this is tell me if i'm true to the spirit of that this is the point at which i launch myself at you sink my fingers into your neck and shout, you damned interfering foreigner! Or something like that. No, I was thinking of you more as kind of Captain Hastings. Well, clearly you do, yeah. And your dapper suit.
I think of myself as the murderer. Well, of course, these are exactly the kind of tricks Agatha Christie loves to play. That's right. So what we should say right at the beginning, Tom, because we are are talking about the i think we can reasonably say certainly commercial terms the single most successful british writer probably the single most successful writer of any country in the 20th century um but amazingly there will be some people who haven't read her books but maybe want to so we should probably say at the beginning that there's a spoiler alert yeah we will be giving away i imagine a lot of the um a lot of the culprits and the denouements
and so on yeah um but yeah it's unapologetically unapologetically it's a great subject this tom because we did sherlock combs before we did james bond and i think agatha christie i mean it's extraordinary that she outsold both conan doyle andle and Ian Fleming by a colossal margin. You know, it's one of these things people try to calculate the number of books sold, but we're talking about hundreds of millions in different languages. And you did it in your splendid kind of – I assume that's a Belgian accent. Yes, it is. Yes. But she's very popular in France, incredibly popular in France. They have their own separate adaptations and French literary critics, as we will probably discuss, have written glowing tributes to her.
So it makes sense to take her seriously. I checked in the Bodleian and apparently she is the most translated individual author of all time. I can well believe that. So more than Shakespeare or? Well, easier to translate than Shakespeare, I would imagine. And more accessible, and probably very good if you're learning, also, if you're learning English. Right. So that's a question which I'm sure we'll come to, is that popularity reflective of the global cultural power that Britain had in the 20th century? That's a good question.
I'm sure we'll come to that. I would also say that Agatha Christie is, I mean, it's a classic Sandbrook subject. So a hugely popular, hugely popular figure who tends to be looked down on by the sneery metropolitan elites that you, Dominic, stand firm against. Well, yeah, I mean, I'm glad you say that because some years ago, I mean, about two listeners may remember this. I did a series on the BBC called, which they ended up calling Let Us Entertain You. This was after I'd persuaded them not to call it
Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island, which was their original title. That, I mean, imagine being trapped by a storm on Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island. A terrifying prospect. With a homicidal maniac on the loose. A terrible, talking to you about stanley baldwin um yeah so yeah so they didn't call it that and it was basically about british
culture in the 20th century the british imagination and its export overseas and um i wrote a tie-in book and and for that called uh the great british dream factory which i'm holding up now as i talk to you dominic no one can see it no i know It's nice that you're holding it up for me to see. I'm conjuring up an image using the power of words. And I kicked off the discussion of Agatha Christie in that by listing some of the things that people have said about her. So the American critic Edmund Wilson, for example, said her prose is of a mawkishness and banality, which seems to me almost literally impossible to read.
Bernard Levin said her books are unreadable rubbish, not one of them worth the time of an intelligent adult ruth rendall who obviously was later on a kind of rival of agatha christie or successor and rival said when i read an agatha christie i don't feel as though i have a piece of fiction worthy of the name in front of me and basically people have always looked down on agatha christie and sneered at her and sort of guardian columnists okay i was waiting for you to take use the phrase guardian columnists. Of course. And there it is. So everyone playing Dominic Sandbrook, bingo.
Bingo, yeah. Because if you search on the Guardian website and their comment pages, there are tons of attacks on Agatha Christie saying it's nostalgic, it's snobbish, it's this, that, and the other. All of which actually at the time in the books, it's not. It's not nostalgic because it's set very much in the here and now. And it's not snobbish because she doesn't look down on, as it were, the lower orders.
So as I say, the dream, Dominic Sandbrook subject. And you're brilliant at this. You're absolutely brilliant at this, at picking up on hugely popular figures who are looked down upon and certainly persuading me as you did in um uh the great british dream factory uh and and persuaded me that we should do this subject does that mean tom that one day we can do a podcast about katherine cookson i'm not sure about that i'm not sure about that no because i don't think she's i don't think i i agree that agatha christie her fame and her popularity yeah is in, you know, these are historically intriguing details that are worthy of study. I also think that in and of herself, her relationship to her work is very interesting.
Well, she's a good, the 20th century, Tom, she's a great window into the 20th century. I was only reading earlier today an essay by john lanchester you must be a big admirer i mean he's a brilliant critic john lanchester and he says in that um one of christie's subjects is the 20th century and actually you can trace it through her books from the mysterious affair of styles which was first published in 1920 in america to the last books which are not as good really published in the 1970s but you can track the social and cultural changes through the fiction. And they're very subtle, but they're there.
And it's a really interesting way to think about British culture in the 20th century. Well, if top critics who write for the London Review of Books agree with you, then we're absolutely onto a winner here. We are, we are. We're pleasing the highbrows and the lowbrows. So I think that, I mean, I agree let's let's look at agatha christie as a mirror held up to the 20th century but probably um it would be best to look at uh the life of agatha christie herself because i think there are clues there oh you're gonna i hope you're
gonna keep slipping into this because that will make that will not be irritating at all for the audience okay i think that there are clues in her upbringing and and the two two i think two particularly seismic events in her life that seem to have um do i have to ask first is uh her um her relationship to her parents so she's born 1890 yeah in uh torquay yeah the english rivera the english rivera famous for its brilliant hotels um and actually hotels along the devon coast are quite a theme of her fiction they are um but her parents are, so her father is American and her mother is British. Yes. Born in Dublin.
Yes. From Ireland. Exactly. But, but yeah, she's very, it's a very kind of genteel upbringing. So I think they have, you know, conservatories and a tennis court and. Yes. And libraries and things. Yeah.
All this sort of stuff. Yeah. So the upper middle class, I suppose you'd say they are. But when her when um agatha is and she's agatha miller when she is 11 her father dies and they are left financially embarrassed basically so there is yes there's a kind of i mean it's not it's not like they become poverty stricken but it's it's uncomfortable for someone used to upper middle class life that they have to start economizing and all these kind of things. And that clearly leaves in her mind the memory of how important money is, of how significant social gradations are, all these kind of things that will feed into her fiction. I think that's very astute, Tom.
Do you think the little grey cells there? I think the little grey cells have been absolutely vindicated because i think um she absolutely is aware of the instability and it might seem an odd thing to say about upper middle class life but of course so many people are sort of trying to keep up appearances as it were yeah and playing playing the parts expected of them which is a big theme of agatha christie's. And if you think, as you say, what are we, when she's 11, 1901. So Edwardian England, you know, keeping up appearances, putting on, you know, this is the era of the Kaiser having the wrong deck shoes, very much a favorite theme of the rest of history.
And I think that underpins so much, that the social anxiety of the upper middle classes in the 20th century is a, is a key part of the, of the sort of world of her fiction, but also that sense that everything can go away, can, can melt and dissolve. Yeah,
absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. Well, and when I, when you mentioned that you originally wanted to call your series, Dominic Island's Pleasure Island, which is,
that's a detail I'll never forget. You know, they also wanted to call it some. No, what? They wanted to call it, at one point, they wanted to call it, I'm not kidding. They really wanted to call it For Your Pleasure. It's like a Durex advert. That's exactly what I said.
I said, that's written on machines in the gentleman's toilets. I mean, you cannot call it that. Okay, but when you mentioned, I said, imagine being trapped on that island with a homicidal maniac on the loose. Of course, they're never homicidal maniacs. She's not actually that kind of writer. They are always people. I mean, that's the whole thing, isn't it? of her critics have done because the killers as you say are not you know there's no fear of the lower orders in the books the fear comes from within from within the sort of the middle class isn't it and actually you're completely right tom that people are often motivated by by secrets by a kind of grinding
gnawing anxiety about losing about being exposed or something like that and my money and my money is by by far the single biggest motivation but um of killers and agatha christie's books but the second would be sexual desire yeah jealousy or uh people being spurned or whatever and that of course um is the second uh terrible experience that agatha christie goes through and i say agatha christie rather than agatha miller because um she marries a guy called archibald that's right christie archie christie who's very dashing isn't he so she meets him at a ball um outside torquay in i think 1912 checking my notes from the bodleian. Very good. He proposes in 1913. And of course, in 1914, the war breaks out and he is in the Air Force.
He's in the Royal Flying Corps. Exactly. He's a real pioneer. But also, that's a very dashing thing to be in the Great War. I mean, she's done... A moustache, I assume. I imagine him with a moustache. I imagine him as a sort of...
Yeah, well, he becomes quite a sort of rakish figure in the kind of Christie imagination, obviously, mythology because of his behaviour in the 1920s. But he must have been a tremendous catch. So Agatha had been a very shy and always was incredibly shy kind of bookish. She didn't go to school. She was kind of self-taught. She sort of reads all these books in her father's library.
She goes to parties and things. Somebody says to her at one point or says to her mother, your daughter is a beautiful dancer, but she doesn't know how to talk. But obviously Archie Christie is a great catch. So they're married. She works as a volunteer nurse in the First World War, which I think is massively important. Where she learns about poisons.
She learns about poisons. But also she poisons but also she's she's clearing up you know cleaning up service and stuff covered in blood i mean she talks at one point she gave an interview one of the only interviews she ever gave was the imperial war museum and um she talked in that about um picking up basically bits of people and you know putting them into the furnace but that kind of i mean that kind of gore is not a feature of the novels is it no and it wouldn't they wouldn't be successful if it if it was actually yeah i think it's the you're the the death is always there is no hannibal lecter there's no definitely not but yeah so then she she writes i mean we can come back to the fiction a second but and she her first book mysterious affair at styles 1920 in america and then
published 1921 in Britain. And that introduces Poirot. Poirot. And we can come back to Poirot, I think, as well as a refugee character. But then, so she writes a series of books in the 1920s. I think there's so much actually to be said about why the 20s, why is it that Agatha Christie is successful at this point in time? What is?
Do you want to do that now or do you want to get on to the sex? Okay, let's get on to the sex and then we'll come back to that. Tom Holland, I know how his mind works. So she's quite a successful writer. She's had a great hit with The Murder of Roger Ackroyd, which is arguably the single greatest detective novel of all time. She's 36 years old. And she and Archie, he's a stockbroker,
and they live in Sunningdale in Berkshire, real kind of home county stockbroker belt. And real kind of everything that you would expect on a Sunday evening ITV crime drama. Yeah, absolutely. Home counties, stockbroker and seething sexual jealousy. Yes. Well, this is what you clearly wanted to get onto, Tom. So they've kind of grown apart. He spends all his time playing golf in the city. And he basically, they have a row, and he's just said to her, I'm actually, I've fallen in love with my golfing partner,
who's called Nancy Neal. Now, a fantastic fact, Tom, is that one of our listeners is related to Nancy Neal. Oh, really? Because he sent me a message when he found out. He's called John Browning. He's a member of the Restless History Club, which you too can join at restlesshistorypod.com.
So he gave us a brilliant opportunity for advertising our club. But also he says Nancy Neal was the other woman and she was my maternal grandmother's cousin. They were both the daughters of railway officials. And their father was a senior railway officer who took charge of Queen Victoria's railway travel from London to Carlisle when she went to Balmoral. I remember my grandmother saying that her cousin's husband had previously been married to Agatha Christie, but she never mentioned the scandal. Probably not surprisingly. So anyway, yes.
So Nancy Neill is the other woman. And Agatha, on the night of the 3rd of December 1926, she goes upstairs to kiss their seven-year-old daughter goodnight. And then she comes back downstairs and she gets in the car, which is, I think, a Morris. And then she disappears. Amazing. And the car is found abandoned.
Yeah, by sort of gravel pit or something. I can't remember. Or clay pit or something of that kind. And ten days go by and it's this colossal media sensation. So people send the newspapers. Of course, it's the heyday of the kind of popular press, of the sort of the Harmsworth press empire and so on. So they all get involved. They hire Dorothy L. Sayers, a rival, to visit her house looking for clues.
Psychics they get, don't they? So Arthur Conan Doyle, I mean, he consults a medium. Yeah, but I mean, Arthur Conan Doyle at this stage in his life consults a medium to tell him what pair of trousers to put on. So I mean, yeah, massive press sensation. A lot of people say it's a stunt or that she's dead or Archie has murdered her or, you know, who knows. And then 10 days later, famously, she turns up in the Swan Hydro Hotel in Harrogate under an assumed name.
And she's basically spent the last 10 days playing bridge and dancing and doing all this stuff with the other guests. But the weird thing, Tom, as you may know, is the assumed name she takes on is mrs neil yeah in other words she names herself after the other woman and people have never worked out really whether it was um designed to embarrass so what do you think because there are many theories on this aren't there and they're never conclusively conclusively answered it's really hard to say some kind of breakdown i guess a breakdown coupled with possibly an attempt to you know maybe she's hoping that her husband will come and kind of rescue her and come to his senses or something um or maybe it's something she embarked on and then once she'd
embarked on it you know in the sort of moment of madness yeah then she was stuck with it she couldn't kind of after two days say she just thought god i'm gonna have to brazen this out and carry on doing this for weeks i don't know it's impossible i mean she never talked about the degree to which she writes about these kind of dramas and then she finds herself kind of trapped in one the love triangle which is so well in a theme okay so so here is my here's my theory on this so in preparation for this i read two of her her greatest works uh murder on the nile death on the nile tom sorry death on the nile and um evil under the sun evil under the sun yeah and they're both written i think kind of 39 41 something like that i mean yes so around the beginning of the second world war and massive spoiler alerts if you haven't read them or seen them and you would like to just
blank this bit out but basically the plot of both of them revolve around a couple yeah the husband or the the fiance or the male partner seems to run off with a much more glamorous wealthier sexually attractive woman yeah who then dies who gets murdered yes and it turns out that all along the male partner has has actually stayed faithful to his original female partner and both of them have have teamed up together to commit the murder it's a trick to kill the the other the woman that you think is the the other woman who's stolen him yeah and actually all along it's it's the other woman who ends up dead i mean that's kind of very very interesting it seems to me applying my little gray cells uh back but also of course uh you know they are murderers so there's a certain degree of kind of wish fulfillment there but also a feeling of guilt perhaps that you are engaging in the wish fulfillment am i being am i being too psychologically
blank this bit out but basically the plot of both of them revolve around a couple yeah the husband or the the fiance or the male partner seems to run off with a much more glamorous wealthier sexually attractive woman yeah who then dies who gets murdered yes and it turns out that all along the male partner has has actually stayed faithful to his original female partner and both of them have have teamed up together to commit the murder it's a trick to kill the the other the woman that you think is the the other woman who's stolen him yeah and actually all along it's it's the other woman who ends up dead i mean that's kind of very very interesting it seems to me applying my little gray cells   back but also of course uh you know they are murderers so there's a certain degree of kind of wish fulfillment there but also a feeling of guilt perhaps that you are engaging in the wish fulfillment am i being am i being too psychologically
tom i actually once again i um now we're recording this on a day where somebody on twitter said whenever i'm i i say you're being very generous tom or something like that it means i think you're talking absolute rubbish but actually i think you're you're dead right i hadn't thought of that before but i think it's so the portrait of the killers in both those books death and then art it's a it's very kind of double-edged isn't it because the um it is wishful film but at the same time there is a dread of the of the character of the sort of raffish yeah you know sexually attractive male the um in in evil under the sun the the the woman who um turns out to be complicit in the murder but is presented in a kind of very positive light um but she she
tom i actually once again i um now we're recording this on a day where somebody on twitter said whenever i'm i i say you're being very generous tom or something like that it means i think you're talking absolute rubbish but actually i think you're you're dead right i hadn't thought of that before but i think it's so the portrait of the killers in both those books death and then art it's a it's very kind of double-edged isn't it because the um it is wishful film but at the same time there is a dread of the of the character of the sort of raffish yeah you know sexually attractive male the um in in evil under the sun the the the woman who um turns out to be complicit in the murder but is presented in a kind of very positive light   but she   she
doesn't tan she doesn't go that's right she's bookish um so she's a bit of a self-portrait you think a bit except of course that hanks christ Christie is also famous as a surfer, isn't she? A surfer? Yeah. Did I hear that correctly? Yeah. Like a surfer as in? As in the Beach Boys.
doesn't tan she doesn't go that's right she's bookish   um so she's a bit of a self-portrait you think a bit except of course that hanks christ Christie is also famous as a surfer, isn't she? A surfer? Yeah. Did I hear that correctly? Yeah. Like a surfer as in? As in the Beach Boys.
As in Big Sur or something in California? Yeah, there's a famous photo of her clutching a surfboard. Is there? I've never seen this. Wow. You're the top historian of Agatha Christie. You must have seen it. No, well, I'm clearly not. Well, maybe I the top historian of Agatha Christie. You must have seen it. No, well, I'm clearly not.
Well, maybe I'm imagining that. I'll go and check that. I think she did. But I think the idea of the kind of the bookish, almost mousy, white-skinned, uncharismatic, poor kind of church mouse who then turns out to be, you know, to have kept her man and to be a murderer i don't know i just wonder if perhaps there's a certain degree that's nice
but also that takes us back to the climates of the 20s when the book started because the sort of small scale nature of them i think is really important to their success and that's those sort of characters so poirot himself himself is kind of like that, Tom, in the sense that, of course, he's larger than life in lots of ways. But I always think with Poirot... Do you want to just describe him for people who may not have read any novels? So Poirot is, what is he, five foot four or something? He's very round.
He has a head like an egg. He is a Belgian refugee. To make him a Belgian refugee is so daring in 1920. Today, when you watch the David Suchets, he seems a nostalgic, backward-looking figure. But it's the equivalent of making him a Syrian refugee or a Ukrainian refugee today. He's a very contemporary figure.
He lives in a brand-new flat. His flat is often described of, you know, it's described as all geometrically arranged. Which they get very, very well in the Souchet. They do, perfectly. They're perfectly. Everything has to be just so. He's utterly unheroic.
He's physically unprepossessing. He's frightened of kind of paddling, let alone of swimming. I remember there was a brilliant thing where he had to, in the David S was a brilliant thing where he had to, in the David Suchet one, where he had to cross a stile. And you could see him, the look of horror on David Suchet's face. And then he kind of waddles off down the side of the field.
He's always worried about getting his kind of patent leather shoes dirty in his spats. But in 1920, all of that is really bracing because the detectives that you're used to are sherlock holmes and the and his imitators sherlock holmes and his rivals so they're all sort of quite tall beaky men in kind of massive tweed coats who are always kind of herring after hounds on moors down se sewers. Yeah, or like they want a blue for pugilism at Cambridge or something. And Poirot is absolutely not from that cloth. So I always think he is a detective for an age, a post-First World War age,
that is nervous about kind of masculine heroics and about violence and about the gallant hero and all those kinds of things but he's also an outsider he's an outsider absolutely and this is why one of the really interesting interestingly foolish things that people say about agatha christie is so foolish they say well she's xenophobic but actually a time and again in christie's books people say that damn foreigner what is he a Frenchman or something? And they either make him look like fools or they're the murderer
or they're exposed as a sort of oafish reactionary. Christie is very clever in her portrayal of Englishness. There's a sort of edge to it. And I think that's one of the reasons, incidentally, why he's so popular in France. Poirot is a character, but also Christie is a novelist. Because it paints, in many ways, quite an unflattering picture of British self-satisfaction, complacency, introversion,
all those kinds of things. Well, it's a very interesting example of this. And it wasn't about xenophobiaophobia but it was about sexism yeah watching um evil under the sun yesterday so i read the novel and then watched the adaptation of it by andy horowitz very good and i was watching it with um katie my daughter and the portrayal of the the murdery the the kind of glamorous other woman who ends up um being murdered and lots of people say, oh, she's an evil figure. You know, she's destroying the marriage. She's a man eater.
She's going to get murdered. She's going to deserve all she gets. And Katie said, oh, no, I'm not sure about that. I don't think you should be. Were you in danger of being cancelled in your own household, Tom? Well, she was picking up on something that was, you know, it was sexist. It was a sexist approach. And because it was Agatha Christie and because it was set up on something that was, you know, it was sexist. It was a sexist approach. And because it was Agatha Christie and because it was set up when it was, it was entirely, you know, you could imagine, yes, this is the attitude that you, the viewer or the reader are meant to have.
But of course, this turns out to be sand thrown in your eyes, dust thrown in your eyes, because actually it turns out that, you know, Poirot says she is a victim. She's always been a victim. She hasn't been a man eater. She's been ripped off, you know, predatory men have stolen all her money. And it turns, you know, you are, she deceives you. And she, she kind of panders to people's prejudices. I think that's absolutely right. Kind of turns them on the head. And she does that with, with, with kind of British chauvinism as well. She does it again and again. And I think that's one of the really interesting things that people often say about Christie. Well, her books are full of stereotypes, kind of vicars, doctors, you know, as you say, man-eating women, all these kinds of things.
But so often she'll feed you the stereotype. But that's a trick. And she's playing actually with your expectations. She knows that you are carrying so much baggage. And then she sort of pulls the rug out from under you. And I think what's really also interesting in the context of she's writing Between the Wars, in a period of great social change, and then, of course, some of her best books in the 1940s, amid the sort of turmoil of the Second World War, and then the Labour government in Britain, the sort of the Attlee government, all the time, these people are conscious that the sort of turmoil of the Second World War, and then the Labour government in Britain, the sort of the Attlee government.
All the time, these people are conscious that the sort of plates are shifting under their feet and you don't really know who anybody is. You know, new people are moving in, the old guard have lost power, all of this kind of thing. And they talk again and again. You know, I don't know,
those people who bought the house down the road, they say they were in, you know, the East, but I don't you know that sort of thing and then it turns out there's all kinds of secrets and sort of assumed identities and kind of love children and all this kind of stuff yeah and some behaving badly to parents and and so on yeah young tension between the generations yeah i think i think we should take a break at this point uh and i think that when we come back, we should look perhaps at ancient history and Christianity. Oh, Tom, that's absolutely scandalous behavior. Yes. All right. We'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The
Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com Hello, welcome back. We are looking at Agatha Christie as a mirror held up to the 20th century. But I promised that we would look at two intriguing themes, ancient history and Christianity.
Dominic, I mean, I'm not exaggerating, am I? And they are both significant. Well, ancient history, because of course she married an archaeologist. So after the Archie thing all blew up, she then married the archaeologist Max Malowan. And people were very unkind because she was, I think, 14 years his senior. Yes, a Macron-esque relationship. Well, I was going to say, by Macron standards, I mean, they're practically born in the same month. And people used to say, oh, well, you know, Max is interested in old relics and archaeologists are only interested in the older you are and stuff. But actually, they had a very seems to be a very contented marriage.
多米尼克，我的意思是，我可没有夸大其词，对吧？而且这两点都很重要。嗯，古代历史，因为她当然嫁给了一位考古学家。所以在阿奇那档子事闹大之后，她嫁给了考古学家马克斯·马洛温。当时人们觉得很不厚道，因为我记得她比他大14岁。没错，这是一段颇具“马克龙风格”的恋情。哦，我正要说呢，按马克龙的标准来看，我的意思是，他们俩简直可以说是同一个月出生的。过去人们常说，哦，好吧，你知道的，马克斯对古代遗物感兴趣，考古学家只对年纪越大的人感兴趣之类的话。但实际上，他们的婚姻非常美满，似乎非常幸福。
And she would accompany him on these incredible groundbreaking mid-century archaeological digs. And kind of she met him. She was out in Iraq with Leonard Woolley, who that's right. Excavated Earth. I mean, he's very, very high. And she she'd always been interested in that because because when she left school, her mother was ill. And this, you know, as with Lord Carnarvon going to Egypt, you go to Egypt if you are, you know,
而且她会陪他去参加这些令人难以置信的、开创性的世纪中期考古发掘。她其实是在那之前认识他的。当时她在伊拉克与伦纳德·伍利在一起，没错，就是那个。发掘了乌尔遗址。我的意思是，他在业内地位非常非常高。而且她——她一直对考古很感兴趣，因为当她离开学校时，她的母亲生病了。这就有点像——正如卡那封勋爵去埃及一样，如果你觉得——
you're a bit seedy, a bit under the weather, go and spend the winter months in Luxor or Cairo. And so she goes with her mother to Cairo when she's about 18. And I think it has obviously a kind of huge impact on her so I'm sure that that that is kind of an aspect of why she she falls for Max Malouan who um I I cited in Persian Fire he wrote a very good article on Cyrus the Great this is a brilliant opportunity for you to advertise your book of Persian Fire yeah thank you um and also she she
身体有点虚弱、有些不适，你就会去卢克索或开罗度过冬天的几个月。所以她大约18岁时跟着母亲去了开罗。我想这显然对她产生了巨大的影响，所以我确信这也是她迷恋马克斯·马洛温的一个方面。我在《波斯之火》中提到过他，他写过一篇关于居鲁士大帝的非常好的文章。这是你宣传你的书《波斯之火》的绝佳机会。是的，谢谢。嗯……而且她还——
wrote um she wrote a play about akhenaten friend of the show which is terrible oh no it's terrible so basically basically it's um it's it's a kind of standard agatha christie murder novel transplanted to the 18th dynasty so you've got horam heb who is the the general under akhenaten um who is described as being a pukasarb. So he's like the colonel who's a bore about Simla and Puna and all that. And his wife, Mutnojmet, she undulates her body menacingly. Oh, no. It's one of the stage descriptions.
她写过——她写过一部关于阿肯纳顿的戏剧，本节目的老朋友们都知道，这部剧太糟糕了。哦，不，它太糟糕了。所以基本上，基本上它是一个——它是一个标准的阿加莎·克里斯蒂式的谋杀小说，被移植到了古埃及第十八王朝。所以你有了霍伦海布，也就是阿肯纳顿手下的将军——他被描述为一个古板的老顽固。他就像那种对西姆拉和浦那的旧事喋喋不休、令人厌烦的陆军上校。他的妻子穆特努杰迈特，她的身体会做出充满威胁感的起伏动作。哦，不。这是舞台说明之一。
I'd happily see that. And she's very snooty about Queen Tea, who holds on to her old-fashioned fashions of dress. So is this an adaptation? Because Chrissie wrote one of her whodunnits, Death Comes as the End, I think it was, was set in ancient Egypt. Is this an adaptation of that?
我很乐意去看那个。而且她对泰伊王后非常傲慢，因为泰伊王后一直保持着老派的着装风格。那么，这是一部改编作品吗？因为克里斯蒂写过一部她的“谁干的”风格的小说，我想那是《死亡终究到来》，背景就是古埃及。这改编自那部小说吗？
No, it's different. It's literally about Tutankhamen and all that. So she dabbled twice in ancient Egypt. Yeah. But, of that? No, it's different. Oh, right. It's literally about Tutankhamen and all that. So she dabbled twice in ancient Egypt. Yeah. But of course, some of her books are set,
不，不一样。它讲的就是图坦卡蒙和那些事。所以她涉足古埃及两次。是的。但是，这是改编吗？不，不同。哦，对了。它讲的就是图坦卡蒙和那些事。所以她涉足古埃及两次。是的。但是当然，她的一些书的背景是——
so Murder in Mesopotamia is set on an archaeological dig and there's supposedly a portrait in that of Leonard Woolley's wife, who clearly was not highly regarded by the other archaeologists.
比如《美索不达米亚谋杀案》，背景是一个考古发掘现场，里面据称有伦纳德·伍利妻子的画像，这位妻子显然不太受其他考古学家的待见。
And Death on the Nile, there's a murder attempt at the great statues of Ramses II at Abu Simnel. That's right. And actually, I mean, one of the interesting things about Christian is that her books basically take place in two different kinds of places.
而在《尼罗河上的惨案》中，阿布辛拜勒的拉美西斯二世巨像那里发生了一起谋杀未遂事件。没错。事实上，我的意思是，关于克里斯蒂的一个有趣之处在于，她的书基本上发生在两种不同类型的地方。
They take place in rural England, in rural, in sort of St. Mary Mead or Chipping Claycorn and these sort of invented… Or islands. Yeah, or islands. Off Cornwall. Yeah, islands of Devon and sort of stuff. But also they take place in what you might call, I suppose, it's the decaying mid-century British
它们发生在英国乡村，在乡村里，比如圣玛丽梅德或奇平克莱科恩以及诸如此类虚构的地方……或者岛屿。是的，或者岛屿。康沃尔海岸外。是的，德文郡的岛屿之类的地方。但它们也发生在你可以称之为——我猜——正在衰落的世纪中期英国——
imperial periphery. They don't tend to be in British colonies, but they're places that are kind of maybe informal colonies. Egypt or Mesopotamia. Egypt, exactly. Or people travelling back, i.e. murder on the Orient Express. The Stamboul train kind of thing.
帝国的边缘地带。它们通常不在英国殖民地，而是那些可能算是非正式殖民地的地方。埃及或美索不达米亚。正是埃及。或者人们在旅途中，也就是《东方快车谋杀案》。伊斯坦布尔列车那种类型。
And that obviously adds to their appeal the exoticism so the ancient history i think i mean that gives her another string to her bow that none of her competitors have dorothy el sayers and uh marjorie ellingham so on who are so rooted in the sort of the cut glass i mean they've got all detectives lord peter whimsy and people like that who, I think, very badly because they're so firmly rooted in the world of the sort of interwar British high society in that world. But then, Tom, you want to talk about Christianity. Now, lots of people will be wondering how you're going to get Christianity in,
这显然增加了它们的吸引力，也就是异域情调。所以我认为古代历史——这为她的弓上添了一根新弦，这是她的任何竞争对手——多萝西·L·塞耶斯、玛乔丽·埃林汉姆等等——所没有的。她们深深植根于那种纯正的阶层中，我的意思是，她们拥有诸如彼得·威姆西勋爵这样的人物和类似的角色。我认为，这些人写得很糟糕，因为他们太深深植根于两次世界大战之间的英国上流社会那个世界了。但是，汤姆，你想谈谈基督教。现在，很多人都会好奇你要怎么把基督教扯进来，
but I think I know how you're going to do it. It's important, isn't it, within the moral world of the detective novel? Yeah. Christie writes, both with Poirot and with Miss Marple, that there is good and evil, that there is right or wrong, that there are absolute moral standards. And that in a sense, that framework of morality is the kind of philosophical equivalent to the island on which everyone is stuck or the manor house that's been cut off by the fog. The pleasure island. The pleasure island, exactly. So it's not as though kind of Nietzschean superheroes are going to be part of the plot who deride conventional standards of morality and think there is nothing wrong with killing, say.
但我猜我知道你要怎么做。在侦探小说的道德世界里，这很重要，对吧？是的。克里斯蒂无论是通过波洛还是马普尔小姐都在传达：善与恶是分明的，对与错是分明的，存在绝对的道德标准。从某种意义上说，这种道德框架就是哲学家眼中的“孤岛”（每个人都被困在上面）或“被大雾隔绝的庄园”的等价物。快乐之岛。正是快乐之岛。所以，这并不意味着尼采式的超人会成为情节的一部分，去嘲笑传统的道德标准，认为杀戮之类的行为并没有什么错。
You know, there is no, I said there was no Hannibal Lecter. It's precisely the fact that there is no Hannibal Lecter. There is no i said there was no hannibal lecter it's precisely the fact that there is no hannibal lecter there is no serial killer there is never anyone i think i i i probably haven't read enough agatha christie's to be absolutely firm about this but by and large the murderers accept the moral frameworks the moral standards yeah and these moral standards are christian because agatha christie was actually quite a devout Christian. Well, she is a devout Christian. She's a quiet Christian. She's not kind of tub-thumping.
你知道，没有——我说了没有汉尼拔·莱克特。恰恰是没有汉尼拔·莱克特这一事实。没有——我说了没有汉尼拔·莱克特，恰恰是没有汉尼拔·莱克特这一事实。没有连环杀手，从来没有任何人——我想，我可能没有读过足够多的阿加莎·克里斯蒂的小说，无法对此做出绝对肯定的判断——但总的来说，凶手们接受了道德框架、道德标准。是的，这些道德标准是基督教的，因为阿加莎·克里斯蒂实际上是一个相当虔诚的基督徒。嗯，她是个虔诚的基督徒。她是一个安静的基督徒。她不是那种大肆宣扬的人。
But I think it is significant and important to explain the style of detective fiction that she does. So there is an argument, Tom, that detective fiction comes into being in the mid-Victorian period. And you could make an argument, I suppose, that detective fiction comes into being. It obviously expresses all kinds of anxieties about an urban, mobile society where crime can strike at any moment and you don't know who's done it because you don't know. You feel discombobulated by the modern world. I suppose you could argue the detective is a substitute for the judgment of God, the sort of divine authority.
但我认为这对于解释她所创作的侦探小说风格具有重大而重要的意义。所以有一种观点认为，汤姆，侦探小说是在维多利亚时代中期诞生的。我想你可以提出这样一个观点，即侦探小说是在此时诞生的。它显然表达了对城市流动社会的各种焦虑，在这样的社会中，犯罪随时可能发生，你不知道是谁干的，因为你不知道。你对现代世界感到迷惑不解。我想你可以辩称，侦探是上帝审判、某种神圣权威的替代品。
I mean, Poirot, Miss Marble. Poirot is often like that, isn't he? They absolutely, they have a kind of knowledge that nobody else does. They kind of, an omniscience almost. I mean, there's often a moment
我的意思是，波洛，马普尔小姐。波洛通常就是这样的，对吧？他们绝对拥有某种其他人所没有的知识。他们几乎有一种全知全能的感觉。我的意思是，通常会有一个时刻——
in a Poirot book, quite early on, where Poirot will say to Hastings, I know who did it. I merely need to talk to four different people and wait for three other crimes before I can assemble people in the library. But I know, all you need to know is three things, the drop of wax, the timetable, and the fact that he placed a bet on so-and-so to win the 330th entry. And that's all you need to
在一本波洛的小说里，很早的时候，波洛会对黑斯廷斯说：“我知道是谁干的。我只需要跟四个人谈谈，再等另外三起犯罪发生，然后我就可以把大家召集到图书馆里了。但我知道，你只需要知道三件事：一滴蜡、时刻表，以及他在某某人身上押注赢得330场比赛的事实。”这就是你所需要知道的——
know. And you know, there's a godlike figure um and interestingly christy so she believes in the death penalty miss marple in 450 at paddington which is 1957 so there's a moratorium for the death penalty in the 1950s and miss marple says of the killer i'm really very very sorry they've abolished capital punishment because i think anyone i think ought to hang it is the villain um christia herself says in her autobiography um people who kill are evil um even if they might deserve pity you cannot spare them any more than you could spare the man who staggers out from a plague-stricken village in the middle ages to mix with innocent and healthy children in a nearby village not wearing
全部。你知道的，这是一个神一般的人物，嗯，有趣的是，克里斯蒂——所以她相信死刑。《帕丁顿列车4点50分》（1957年作品）中的马普尔小姐——当时在20世纪50年代有一个暂停死刑的时期——马普尔小姐谈到凶手时说：“我真的、真的很遗憾他们废除了死刑，因为我认为任何人——我认为都应该被绞死。”这就是那个恶人。——克里斯蒂本人在她的自传中说：“杀人的人是邪恶的，即使他们可能值得同情，你也绝不能饶恕他们，就像你不能饶恕中世纪时从一个瘟疫肆虐的村庄里蹒跚而出、去和附近村庄里无辜健康的儿童混在一起的、不戴口罩的人一样——
his mask um yeah yeah and actually, the fascinating thing, I think, about Christie and her Christianity and the World Wars and the era of the World Wars in which she's writing is that so often there are conversations in her books about evil. So in Evil Under the Sun, I mean, the title, you know, evil is foregrounded. But, Tom, there's that brilliant moment that you must surely have enjoyed where there's the vicar at the beginning.
哦，是的，是的。”事实上，我认为关于克里斯蒂、她的基督教信仰以及世界大战（她正是在世界大战的时代进行写作）最迷人的一点是，在她的书中经常会有关于“恶”的对话。所以在《阳光下的罪恶》中，我的意思是，书名（你知道的）将“恶”置于最显眼的位置。但是，汤姆，有一个精彩的片段，你一定很喜欢，就是开头的那个牧师。
I know we have a lot of vicars who listen to this podcast, the Reverend Tim Vasby-Burney, the Reverend Marcus Walker, and so on. There's the vicar who's kind of absolutely obsessed with evil, isn't there? Yes, but his obsession with evil is one of the things that might make him a suspect. Yeah, because people think he's a maniac. Well, he's a maniac, isn't he? Monsieur Poirot, evil is real. It is a fact. I believe in evil like I believe in good. It exists. It's powerful. It walks the earth.
我知道有很多收听这个播客的牧师，蒂姆·瓦斯比-伯尼牧师、马库斯·沃克牧师等等。有一个对“恶”绝对着迷的牧师，对吧？是的，但他对“恶”的着迷正是让他成为嫌疑人的原因之一。是的，因为人们觉得他是个狂人。嗯，他是个狂人，对吧？“波洛先生，恶是真实的。这是一个事实。我相信恶，就像我相信善一样。它存在。它很强大。它行走在人世间。”
He stopped. His breath was coming fast. He wiped his forehead with his handkerchief and looked suddenly apologetic. I'm sorry I got carried away, he said. Tom, that's just like, that's what I'm like when I'm listening to you. Well, I don't know. I think that's a little harsh because he is going on about kind of painted Jezebels and he's accusing the murderee
他停了下来。他的呼吸变得急促。他用手绢擦了擦额头，突然显得有些歉意。“很抱歉我刚才太激动了，”他说。汤姆，这简直就像——这就像我听你说话时的样子。嗯，我不知道。我觉得这有点严厉，因为他一直在喋喋不休地谈论那些涂脂抹粉的 Jezebel（荡妇），并且指责《阳光下的罪恶》中的受害者是个恶魔。
in Evil Under the Sun of being evil. And of course he turns out not to be evil. That's the whole twist. So he's part of that kind of, the dust thrown in the eyes. But Poirot does not deny that there is evil. No. He agrees that there is evil and Poirot and
而当然，他证明了自己并非恶人。这就是整部小说的反转所在。所以他是那种抛向人们眼中的烟雾弹的一部分。但波洛并没有否认恶的存在。没有。他同意恶的存在，而且波洛和——
Marple both say again and again there is such a thing as evil um but what's really interesting so in this sort of pressure island series one of the conceits of it was that we were going to be tracing back um everything to Dickens and uh actually it turned out Dickens was Agatha Christie's favorite writer and Dickens of course portrays evil favourite writer. And Dickens, of course, portrays evil as well. And also Dickens is one of the great progenitors of detective. Yeah, Inspector Bucket in Bleak House. Inspector Bucket in Bleak House. But in Dickens, evil is always expressed kind of physically.
马普尔小姐都一再表示，世上确实存在恶。但真正有趣的是——在这个“快乐之岛”系列中，它的一个构思是，我们将把一切追溯到狄更斯。而事实上，后来发现狄更斯是阿加莎·克里斯蒂最喜欢的作家，狄更斯当然也将恶——最喜欢的作家。而狄更斯当然也将恶描绘得淋漓尽致。而且狄更斯也是侦探小说的伟大开拓者之一。是的，《荒凉山庄》里的巴克特警探。正如《荒凉山庄》里的巴克特警探。但在狄更斯笔下，“恶”总是以某种物理形态表现出来。
So you're a dwarf. Yes, you writhe. You've got a hunchback or whatever. Rather like in Shakespeare or something. But in Agatha Christie, the whole point about evil is that some of the really evil people are otherwise absolutely well-adjusted, sensible, normal characters. It's not like Ian Fleming, where they've all got three hands or they're too hairy or something, the criminal masterminds.
所以你是个侏儒。是的，你扭曲着身体。你有驼背或者诸如此类的特征。有点像莎士比亚的戏剧或其他作品里那样。但在阿加莎·克里斯蒂的小说中，关于恶的精髓在于，一些真正邪恶的人在其他方面完全是适应良好、通情达理、极其正常的角色。这不像伊恩·弗莱明的作品，那些犯罪头目们都长着三只手，或者毛发过多之类的。
And actually, that's the fascinating thing, I think, because in 20th century culture generally, I think especially in mid-century when Christie was writing, it's full of stuff about the evil that lurks within us. You know, all the kind of Lord of the Flies kind of stuff, or indeed Gollum in The Lord of the Rings. And so Christie, again and again, characters say, so there's a book called Appointment with Death, and there's a French psychologist called Dr. Girard, and he says, there are such strange things buried down in the unconscious, a lust for power, a lust for cruelty, a savage desire to tear and rend. We shut the door on them and we deny them conscious life, but sometimes they are too strong. And that kind of, well, yes, I mean, admittedly, a lot of people will be distracted by the quite superb accident.
事实上，我认为这才是最迷人的地方，因为在20世纪的文化中，尤其是在克里斯蒂写作的世纪中期，到处都充斥着关于“潜藏在我们内心的恶”的内容。你知道的，所有那些《蝇王》之类的内容，或者《指环王》里的咕噜。所以克里斯蒂在书中一次又一次地借角色之口表达——比如有一本书叫《与死神有约》，里面有一个法国心理学家叫吉拉德博士，他说：“在潜意识深处埋藏着如此奇怪的东西：对权力的渴望、对残酷的渴望、撕裂和撕碎的野蛮欲望。我们对它们关上大门，否认它们的意识生命，但有时它们过于强大。”这种观点——好吧，是的，我的意思是，诚然，许多人会被那个相当精彩的偶然事件所分散注意力。
But... Well, that's the kind of stuff you would expect from a French psychologist. But she believes it and Poirot believes it. Well, and Miss Marple believes it. Because actually, Miss Marple is one of the kind of the bleakest fictional creations of the 20th century. Charlie, that's a big claim. She suspects that everywhere she looks, there is evil. And she always turns out to be right.
但是……嗯，这就是那种你会从一个法国心理学家身上听到的言论。但她相信这一点，波洛也相信这一点。嗯，马普尔小姐也相信这一点。因为事实上，马普尔小姐是20世纪最黯淡的小说虚构人物之一。查理，这是一个很大的论断。她怀疑自己所到之处皆是恶。而事实证明她总是对的。
And what she sees is the evil. I know this is an absolute laugh, but people will say this is a terrible misuse of the phrase, but she sees the banality of evil. So she looks at the goings on in a village and she says, I can see the hatred, the jealousy, the resentment, the greed that festers in even the most ordinary household. So actually, when you read those, especially, I mean, I read them when I was a teenager, absolutely adored them because I wanted to know who did it. But now reading them later and thinking about people reading these books, because the Miss Marple books tend to, the best ones are written basically 1940s, thinking about people reading them at the same time, the moving finger or something.
而她所看到的就是恶。我知道这听起来像个笑话，但人们会说这是对这个短语的糟糕滥用——但她看到了“恶的平庸性”。所以她看着一个村庄里发生的事情，然后说：“我能看到仇恨、嫉妒、怨恨、贪婪，这些情绪在哪怕最普通的家庭里也在溃烂。”所以实际上，当你读到这些书时——特别是，我的意思是，我十几岁时读过它们，绝对爱不释手，因为我想知道是谁干的。但现在大一点再读，并回想人们阅读这些书时的情景——因为马普尔小姐的小说大多是20世纪40年代写的最好的几部——想象人们在阅读它们的同时，也在读报纸上关于二战及其余波中发生的那些可怕恐怖事件的报道。真的，这里面有一种阴暗感，我认为。
They're reading them at the same time that they're reading the newspapers about these dreadful horrors going on during the Second World War and its aftermath. It's really, there is a bleakness there, I think. Yes, but there is also a kind of um compassion that i think also goes back to the christianity perhaps so i was pocket full of rye have you read that yeah um the killer was peter davison in the bbc adaptation in the 1980s
是的，但其中也有一种同情，我认为这也许也可以追溯到基督教。比如《黑麦奇案》，你读过吗？是的，嗯——在1980年代BBC的改编版中，凶手是彼得·戴维森。
which i was a doctor who fan i found very very disappointing yeah yeah so so in that that's a miss marple the so the plot seems to revolve around the um you know four and twenty blackbirds baked in a pie and all that kind of thing and among the the king is in his counting house counting out his money queen is in the what was it parlor making bread and honey the maid was hanging out the washing that's right yes the maid gets killed the maid's called gladys i think isn't she it's always called gladys as in uh why didn't they ask evans um and and in the adaptation i saw she has a kind of clothes peg is that the one with peter davidson yeah kind of clothes stuck on her nose and she's kind of humiliated and it's awful and the whole plot revolves basically around Miss Marple's determination that this maid, who it turns out has been very, very badly emotionally abused.
作为一个《神秘博士》迷，我当时觉得这部剧非常非常令人失望。是的，是的。所以——在那部剧里，那是一个马普尔小姐的故事——这个情节似乎围绕着——你知道的，“二十四只黑画眉烤成一个派”以及诸如此类的事情，其中还有“国王在账房里数钱，王后在什么地方来着？——客厅里吃面包加蜂蜜，女佣在外面晾衣服”。没错，是的，女佣被杀了。女佣好像叫格拉迪斯吧？总是叫格拉迪斯，就像在《为什么不问埃文斯》里一样。在我看过的那个改编版里，她鼻子上夹着一个夹衣服的木夹子——是彼得·戴维森演的那部吗？是的，鼻子上夹着衣夹，她受到了那种羞辱，这太糟糕了。整个情节基本上围绕着马普尔小姐的决心展开：她坚决要为这个女佣讨回公道——后来发现这个女佣在情感上受到了非常非常严重的虐待。
Yeah, that's right. By the killer. She's a foundling. She's been working for Miss Marple and she's gone off to the big house and basically she gets completely fooled and... She's groomed, isn't she? She's groomed. She's groomed. And that, for Miss Marple, is the true evil. Not just that she's been murdered, but that she's been groomed and abused. Because that kind of contradicts the Christy is a snob.
是的，没错。凶手虐待了她。她是个弃儿。她曾在马普尔小姐手下工作，后来去了大宅子，基本上被彻底愚弄了，然后——她被PUA了，对吧？她被PUA了。她被PUA了。对马普尔小姐来说，这才是真正的恶。不仅是因为她被谋杀了，而是因为她被PUA和虐待了。因为这某种程度上反驳了“克里斯蒂是个势利小人”的说法。
No, definitely not a snob. I mean, that's, you know, that's... Well, you can see the debt to Dickens there. Because that's exactly the kind of thing that would have infuriated Dickens as well. Yeah, that's nice, actually. Yes. I mean, Christie, it's interesting, isn't it, that people have this attitude to Christie in Britain,
不，绝对不是势利小人。我的意思是，那是——嗯，你可以从中看到对狄更斯的传承。因为这正是那种也会激怒狄更斯的事情。是的，这其实很不错。是的。我的意思是，克里斯蒂——有趣的是，英国人对克里斯蒂的态度非常独特，我认为，他们会挑剔克里斯蒂，因为他们在国外没有这种态度。我的意思是，我读过一些法国评论家的文章。
uniquely, I think, of stamping on Christie, because they don't have it abroad. I mean, I was reading some of the French critics. Right, so that's great. Okay, so we've done Christie the Christian. Now let's do Christie the post-structuralist. Yeah, well, Christie the modernist. So, I mean, there are arguments by, I mean mean i know some british listeners will be at this point
好吧，那太棒了。好了，我们讨论了基督徒克里斯蒂。现在我们来谈谈后结构主义者克里斯蒂。是的，好吧，现代主义者克里斯蒂。所以，我的意思是，有一些观点认为——我知道有些英国听众此时此刻——
you know either have switched off or just be apoplectic with disbelief but you know people like roland barth jacques barzun uh the novelist michelle i can't i don't know how to pronounce his name actually um huayla beck is it i've never read michelle well back i mean they're massive christy fans and what they see in Christie, the French critics, they say she's a, as you say, Tom,
要么已经关掉了播客，要么正气得目瞪口呆、难以置信——但像罗兰·巴特、雅克·巴尔赞这样的学者，小说家米歇尔——我其实不知道该怎么发音他的名字，嗯，维勒贝克，是吧？我从未读过米歇尔·维勒贝克的书——我的意思是，他们都是克里斯蒂的超级粉丝。法国评论家在克里斯蒂身上看到的是——正如你所说，汤姆，
she is a, a master of form of pure kind of. She really, really is. I wrote an essay about her. Did you? So we talk about the great critics of our time and you've, you've included yourself in that number.
她是一个纯粹形式的大师。她真的是。我写过一篇关于她的论文。真的吗？所以我们谈论我们这个时代的伟大批评家，而你把你自己也算在其中了。
I wrote a structuralist essay on her. Did you? Because certain, certain of the, of the novels have the plotting the structure has a kind of a stark purity that no one will ever better wow there's a big that's so massive spoilers coming up yeah the whole thing with the genre a genre of is that there are rules. Yeah. And you can either go with the rules or you can break them. So whether it's a vampire novel or a Wild West novel or a detective novel, there have to be rules. Actually, Tom, that's true of a history book, right? I mean, readers have complete expectations when we write our books of the way we're going to structure it. You know, we're not going to suddenly enter the story at some point in this like a sort of martin amos character or something yeah so with the
我写了一篇关于她的结构主义论文。真的吗？因为某些——某些小说的情节、结构具有一种质朴的纯粹性，是永远无人能及的。哇，那真是个巨大的——所以接下来会有重大的剧透。整个类型小说的本质在于它有规则。是的。要么你遵守规则，要么你打破规则。因此，无论是吸血鬼小说、美国西部小说还是侦探小说，都必须有规则。事实上，汤姆，历史书也是如此，对吧？我的意思是，读者在我们写书时对我们的结构方式有着完全的期望。你知道的，我们不会突然在故事的某个时刻像马丁·艾米斯笔下的某种角色那样闯入故事中。所以对于——
detective novel you can push it to certain levels beyond which it will fragment and and and break up and the murder of roger ackroyd which you mentioned as and has i think been repeatedly voted the greatest detective novel of all time. The twist in that, and again, massive spoiler alert, is that it is the narrator who is the murderer. And once you've done that, no one else can ever do that. It's been done. And Murder on the Orient Express, it turns out to be everybody. Again, once you've done that, nobody can ever do that.
侦探小说，你可以把它推向某种程度，超越这个程度它就会碎片化和破裂。而你提到的《罗杰·阿克罗伊德谋杀案》，据我所知曾多次被评为史上最伟大的侦探小说。其中的反转——再次发出重大的剧透警告——是叙述者竟然就是凶手。一旦你这么做了，别人就再也无法这样做了。这已经被用过了。《东方快车谋杀案》，最后发现凶手是所有人。同样，一旦你这么做了，就没人能再这样做了。
The Mousetrap, the longest running play of all time, it turns out to be the detective. And I think her best-selling novel, Then There Were None, which was very awkwardly titled in its original iteration, got renamed. That then turned out to be awkward. And then there were none. But there's, again, a kind of stark purity to that,
《捕鼠器》，史上上演时间最长的戏剧，最后发现凶手就是侦探。我想还有她最畅销的小说《无人生还》，它最初出版时的书名非常别扭，后来被改了名。那个名字后来也变得很尴尬。（指英文原书名改动）然后就一个都不剩了。但这其中同样有一种质朴的纯粹性，
that there are 10 people trapped on an island and one by one they all die and there is a solution to it yeah but having to present the solution almost kind of it it destroys the formal beauty of the structure of that plot well not least because actually that that so it's not just that that's formally beautiful but it's also the sort of ideology as it were um reinforces what we were saying earlier. She basically takes a cross section of society and puts them on this, traps them on this pleasure island. And they all die. No, it's not just they all die.
那就是有10个人被困在一个岛上，他们一个接一个地死去，而这一切都有一个解法。是的，但必须把解法呈现出来，这几乎在某种程度上——它摧毁了那个情节结构的形式美。不仅仅是因为那在形式上很美丽，而且它的意识形态，或者说它的内涵，强化了我们刚才所说的话。她基本上截取了社会的一部分人，把他们放在这个岛上，把他们困在这个快乐之岛上。然后他们都死了。不，不仅仅是他们都死了。
It's that they're all killers. They're all sinners. I mean, that's the great. Well, all except one. That's the revelation. Which then turns out to be. But that's the kind of revelation though, isn't it? That they all appear to be, you know, there is the kind of the evil lurks within and the
而是他们全都是杀人犯。他们全都是罪人。我的意思是，这才是最棒的——好吧，除了一个人之外全都是。这就是揭秘所在。结果证明那个例外是——但这正是那种揭秘的意义所在，不是吗？大家似乎都——你知道，恶潜藏在内部，还有——
secrets and they've all killed often for quite banal reasons, greed, jealousy, anger, whatever. You know, they're not serial killers. They're not maniacs. They're not dictators. They're, they are ordinary people whose, whose very human flaws have just taken them a little bit step too far. And I think that's what makes that. I mean, that book is an incredibly bleak book.
秘密，而且他们都杀了人，通常是因为相当平庸的原因：贪婪、嫉妒、愤怒等等。你知道的，他们不是连环杀手。他们不是狂人。他们不是独裁者。他们是普通人，其极度人性化的缺陷让他们稍微越过了界限。我认为正是这一点造就了它。我的意思是，那本书是一本极其阴暗的书。
It is, but it's also the, it's also the book that seems to be certainly the novels that I've read. That seems to be most about what it's like to write a detective novel. It turns out the one of the 10 was actually innocent all along and has structured the whole thing to kill people off to in a way create a mystery that people will want to solve that will attract attention and in that sense that character seems to me the closest to Agatha Christie herself yes that's a nice way of putting it that because some of the some of the books are very self-conscious
确实如此，但这也是——这也是那本最能体现什么是“写侦探小说”的书，至少在我读过的小说里是这样。原来这10个人中有一个人从头到尾都是无辜的，他精心策划了这一切，把人们一个接一个地杀掉，从而以某种方式创造出一个人们想要解开、想要吸引注意力的谜团。从这个意义上说，那个角色在我看来最接近阿加莎·克里斯蒂本人。是的，这样表达很好，因为其中一些——其中一些书非常具有自我意识，
aren't they but that's part of the ethos, that people are always playing parts. And I suppose you can say in some ways the detective is the narrator. But, I mean, in Roger Ackroyd, obviously the murderer is the narrator. The murderer has created them. I mean, you are in the murderer's mind. He has created the whole kind of mise-en-scene. And Roger Ackroyd is so fascinating because it's the 1920s. Absolutely nobody in Roger Ackroyd is who they say they are so they've all
不是吗？但这正是精神内核的一部分，人们总是在扮演角色。我想你可以说，在某种程度上，侦探就是叙述者。但是，我的意思是，在《罗杰·阿克罗伊德谋杀案》中，凶手显然就是叙述者。凶手创造了它们。我的意思是，你正身处凶手的脑海中。他创造了整个场景。而《罗杰·阿克罗伊德谋杀案》之所以如此迷人，是因为那是20世纪20年代。在《罗杰·阿克罗伊德谋杀案》中，绝对没有任何人是他们所说的那样，所以他们全都有——
got secrets there's the you know the country squire actually turns out to be a entrepreneur who's a self-made man or something like that i can't remember all the details and praro is one of them praro is there people think he's there growing cucumbers or something and he turns out to be this detective um but it doesn't really take praro to solve it does it because it's the um the narrator you know the rater has left you and this is the brilliance of christianity the linguistic brilliance there is just a kind of ellipsis or something or there's a gap between two sentences and there's no way when you're reading that because you're so attentive to language there's no way that you would notice that when you're reading it um but
秘密。那个所谓的乡村绅士，实际上是一个白手起家的创业者之类的角色，我记不清所有细节了。而波洛也是其中之一，波洛就在那里，人们以为他在那里种黄瓜什么的，结果他竟然是这个侦探。但这其实不需要波洛来解决，对吧？因为是——叙述者——你知道的，叙述者留下了线索——这就是克里斯蒂的精妙之处，语言上的精妙之处。这中间只是有一种省略号，或者两个句子之间存在一个空白。当你阅读时，因为你对语言如此专注，你绝不可能在阅读时注意到这一点。但——
obviously once you've got to the end and you've you've realized how perfectly it all fits together um then you can go back and read it i think with enormous pleasure actually to work out yeah how she how she tricked because she doesn't because yes because she does obey the rules yeah he's not lying no no no not at all not at all everything he says is true so i think the interesting thing is so the roger roger Ackroyd is now almost 100 years old and people are still producing Agatha Christie adaptations in a way they aren't with, let's say, Dorothy Elsayers. There's no series of Lord Peter Whimsey stories.
显然，一旦你读到了结尾，并意识到这一切是多么完美地契合在一起，那么你就可以回过头去重读它，我想，会带着巨大的愉悦去琢磨——是的，她是如何设计诡计的。因为她确实遵守了规则。是的，他没有撒谎。不，不，绝对没有，绝对没有。他所说的一切都是真的。所以我觉得有趣的是——《罗杰·阿克罗伊德谋杀案》现在已经快100岁了，人们仍在制作阿加莎·克里斯蒂的改编作品，而对多萝西·L·塞耶斯的作品却并非如此。根本没有关于彼得·威姆西勋爵的故事系列。
And the only way of doing that would be to just do them straight. So people wearing spats and sort of Jesus and Worcester style. What is it, do you think, Tom, about Agatha Christie that, you know, there's just been a Why Didn't They Ask Evans adaptation written by Hugh Laurie. There's obviously the Kenneth Branagh films. There are French TV series running all the time. What is it that's meant that she survived the 20th century into the 21st? I think it's the beauty of the plotting. And I think it's the understated moral starkness and coherence that frames that plot. And I think it's a combination of those two.
唯一能做到这一的方法就是原汁原味地去拍。比如人们穿着紧身裤，带着吉斯和伍斯特那种风格。汤姆，你觉得是什么让阿加莎·克里斯蒂——休·劳瑞刚刚编剧了一部《为什么不问埃文斯》的改编作品，显然还有肯尼思·布拉纳的电影，法国的电视剧也在源源不断地播出——是什么让她从20世纪一直延续到了21世纪？我认为是情节的美感。我认为是那种低调的道德严厉性和构建该情节的连贯性。我认为是这两者的结合。
I think the moral climate is really interesting because we don't normally talk about evil now. And most, I would guess, most contemporary 21st century detective novels uh very much rely on kind of social explanations for evil don't they do you think i mean yeah or psychological ones yeah so serial killers it's all you know science of the lam the the key to depravity and evil lies in well it wouldn't even be evil is it i mean it's it's it's either illness or it's society it's it's wrongs that have been done to people when they were young or yeah yeah that kind of stuff or if you're rd lang illness is caused by society so um so so i think that to a degree the kind of the charge of of agatha christie appeals to nostalgia to that extent is true i think nostalgia for a lost moral order a kind of yes a moral order in which everyone accepts
我认为这里的道德氛围非常有趣，因为我们现在通常不谈论“恶”。而且我猜，大多数21世纪当代侦探小说都极大地依赖于对“恶”的社会学解释，对吧？你觉得呢？我的意思是，是的，或者心理学解释。是的，所以连环杀手，全都是——你知道的——犯罪科学，堕落和恶的关键在于——其实这甚至都算不上恶，对吧？我的意思是，要么是疾病，要么是社会原因，要么是人们年轻时遭受的不公，或者——是的，诸如此类。或者如果你是RD·莱恩（精神病学家），疾病就是由社会引起的。所以——所以我觉得，在某种程度上，指责阿加莎·克里斯蒂诉诸怀旧，这种说法在某种程度上是正确的。我认为是对失去的道德秩序的怀旧，一种——是的，一种每个人都接受某种道德基础的道德秩序。
certain moral fundamentals she's morally unsparing in her disapproval of lies, greed. Adultery. Yeah, infidelity. Exactly. All those in a way that is unfashionable, but it's maybe people crave that, I suppose. I also think it's because you can do them without the period trappings in a weird way because she's such a spare writer compared with her contemporaries.
她在对谎言和贪婪的厌恶上是毫不留情的。通奸。是的，不忠。没错。所有这些都以一种不合时髦的方式呈现，但也许人们渴望这种东西，我猜。我也认为这是因为你可以在某种奇怪的情况下剥离时代的浮华来演绎它们，因为与同时代的人相比，她的文风极为精炼。
You don't need to kind of immerse yourself in Stanley Baldwin's Britain. Yes, also, I mean, the Second World War is such a kind of firebreak in British social history. And the world of the Attlee government is obviously profoundly different to the world of anyone for tennis. Yeah. Before that. I mean, it's quite tough for her target class. You know, the upper middle classes, the middle classes.
你不需要让自己沉浸在斯坦利·鲍德温时期的英国。是的，而且，第二次世界大战是英国社会历史上的一道巨大的防火墙。阿attlee（艾德礼）政府的世界显然与“谁想打网球”的世界有着天壤之别。是的。在那之前。我的意思是，对她所针对的阶层来说，日子相当艰难。你知道的，上中产阶级，中产阶级。
They have it quite tough in austerity britain yeah obviously not as tough as everyone else well they think they do yeah they think they do but but that's she she makes she works again with that very cleverly and subtly so unlike pg woodhouse where nothing changes nothing changes you know the world of blanding's castle or the dronesrones Club carries on as though there hasn't been a war and there hasn't been a Labour government. With Christie, it does.
在紧缩时期的英国，他们的日子相当艰难。是的，显然没有其他阶层那么艰难。嗯，他们觉得自己很艰难。是的，他们觉得自己很艰难。但——她巧妙而微妙地运用了这一点。因此，与PG·沃德豪斯不同——在沃德豪斯的小说里，一切都没有改变，没有任何改变。你知道的，布兰丁斯城堡或无人俱乐部的世界继续运转着，仿佛没有发生过战争，也没有工党政府。但在克里斯蒂的小说里，变了。
And so also to that extent, her novels are kind of interesting as a... I think absolutely. So I think if you take a book like A Murderer's Announced, so that's published in 1950. And that I think is one of the best, because it's so subtly done,
因此，从这个意义上说，她的侦探小说作为一种——我认为绝对如此。所以我想如果你拿一本像《谋杀启事》这样的书来看，那是1950年出版的。我认为这是最好的作品之一，因为它的处理极其微妙，
is one of the best books about reading about middle-class discontent with the Attlee government after the Second World War. So, you know, everybody is, they all are sort of a bit scratchy, kind of complaining that they have, you know, it's a world of ration books and identity cards. And you don't really know who anybody is anymore. There are, you know, taxes are so high. New people have moved into the village and they say they did stuff in the war, but you just don't really know who anybody is anymore. There are, you know, taxes are so high. New people have moved into the village and they say they did stuff in the war, but you just don't really know.
这是关于阅读中产阶级对二战后艾德礼政府的不满情绪的最好小说之一。所以，你知道的，每个人都有点暴躁，抱怨说——这是一个充满配给券和身份证件的世界。而且你真的不知道任何人是谁了。你知道的，税收太高了。新搬到村里的人说他们在战争期间做过什么，但你真的不知道任何人是谁。你知道的，税收太高了。新搬到村里的人说他们在战争期间做过什么，但你真的不知道。
People beginning to come back from the empire at this point. So this is just a sort of sense of anxiety and unease. And of this sort of, you get this impression, brilliantly done. I think it's also there actually, another book that was written decades later. Sarah Waters wrote a book called the little stranger a ghost story which i think also captures the sort of the sense of these kind
此时人们开始从帝国各地返回英国。所以这只是一种焦虑和不安的感觉。你会得到这样一种印象，写得极其精彩。我想这也是存在的，另一本几十年后写的书——萨拉·沃特斯写过一本书叫《小陌生人》，这是一部鬼故事，我认为它同样捕捉到了那种穿着粗花呢服装的人们觉得他们的英国在这个福利国家等新世界中已经迷失了的感觉。这种情绪并不是通过直言不讳、大声疾呼来表达的，而是他们不快乐，因为他们的世界已经改变了。克里斯蒂捕捉到了这一点，并将其融入到谋杀情节中，我认为这非常巧妙。我的意思是，我认为在60年代，她写了——那是哪一本？《柏卓姆酒店》。《柏卓姆酒店》和诸如此类的作品。还有《Hickory Dickory Dock》（山核桃大厦谋杀案），我想是这一本，背景是一个年轻人旅社。
of tweedy people that their britain has been lost um in this new world of the welfare state and so on and it's not done to be kind of really outspoken and vociferous about it but they're unhappy because their world has has changed and christy captures that and she weaves that into the murder plot in a way that's really clever i think i mean i think in the 60s she's like but what is it bertram's hotel a bertram's hotel and sort of some of the sort of this one there's hickory dickory dock i think it is which is set in um a hostel for young people. And they're listening to transistors. And the music is sort of 15 years out of date or something.
他们正在听晶体管收音机。而音乐已经落后了15年左右。还有马普尔小姐和那些时髦女郎（Dolly Birds）。是的， exatamente（没错）。这不太搭调。但我认为，至少在20世纪20年代到50年代末之间，这些书是一面极好的镜子。因为它们非常微妙。它们不会把观点硬塞给你，但她以那个时代极少数其他作家那样成功的方式，追踪了世纪中期英国的社会和文化变迁。好吧，所以你看。我认为我们已经证明了在历史播客中探讨阿加莎·克里斯蒂的正当性。
And there's Marple and Dolly Birds. Yeah, exactly. It doesn't quite work. But I think certainly between the 1920s and the end of the 1950s, the books are a brilliant mirror. Because they're so subtle. They don't bang you over the head with it, but she traces in a way that very few other writers of that time did so successfully, the sort of social and cultural changes of mid-century Britain. Well, so there you go. I think that we've justified having Agatha Christie on a history podcast.
你知道吗，汤姆，我一生中最令人振奋的阅读体验之一就是读阿加莎·克里斯蒂的小说。我指的不是最近，而是我大约12岁左右的时候，我真的会为了看书而不吃饭，因为波洛——正如你用甜美的语调，正如我所想象的那样——在叫大家聚集到图书馆里去，你知道的，对嫌疑人们说……我当时就觉得，我宁愿做这件事——除了此刻在这里读这本书、找出凶手是谁之外，我哪儿也不想去。好吧，多米尼克，我把听众们召集到了会客室，召集到了图书馆，我觉得现在我们已经揭晓了答案。答案是什么？基督教。
Do you know, Tom, some of the most exhilarating reading experiences in my life have been with Agatha Christie's. And I'm not talking about recently, but when I was sort of 12 or something, I really would skip meals because Poirot was, you know, in your dulcet tones, just as I imagined it, was telling people to assemble in the library, you know, tell the suspects. And I just would think I would rather do – there's nowhere I'd rather be than reading this right now and finding out who the murderer was. Well, Dominic, I summoned the listeners to the drawing room, to the library, and I feel that now we have revealed the answer. What was the answer? Christianity.
还有古代历史。太惊人了，令人惊叹的揭秘。真令人惊叹，你竟然找到了你从一开始就想找到的答案。谁能猜到呢？伴随着这个美妙的音符，我们解开了这个谜团的谜底。希望大家喜欢。我们很快会再见面，为大家揭晓另一个谜团的谜底。我原本以为你精心策划了这个极其微妙且优雅的结尾，
And ancient history. Amazing, amazing revelation. Amazing that you found the answer you knew you wanted to find. Who would have guessed? And on that incredible note, we've arrived at the solution to the mystery. We hope you have enjoyed it. And we will see you back soon for the solution to another mystery. I thought you had planned this incredibly subtle and elegant ending,
但你只是给出了一个非常平淡的、你知道的，“感谢收听，再见”。这是我惊人戏法的一部分。你原本期待着某种你最终没得到的东西。是的。好吧，我确实期待着某种我没得到的东西。而这正是终极所在。
but you just sort of gave a very generic, you know, thank you for listening. Goodbye. That's part of my amazing kind of trickery. You were expecting something that you didn't get. Yeah. Well, I was expecting something I didn't get. And that was the ultimate.
你落入了我的后现代主义陷阱中。所以，带着这个重磅炸弹，再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们的会员俱乐部刚刚上线。
You fell into my postmodern trap. So on that bombshell, goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家单集以及抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想收听无广告的内容、获取独家加更节目并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。